T
FROM NEW YORK.
♪ ♪
>> THERE'S BEEN QUESTIONS RAISED
ABOUT YOUR TEMPERAMENT AND YOUR
REACTION TO CRITICISM, AND
EDITORIAL USED THE TERM
"IRASCIBLE."
HOW MUCH DOES A SOFT EFFECT TO
DO WITH YOU ARE A WOMAN,
SPECIFICALLY A BLACK WOMAN?
>> ABOUT 99% OF IT.
>> Greg: THE OTHER PERCENT WAS
TOO BUSY GETTING SHOT IN YOUR
CITY.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, ANOTHER
GREAT SHOW TONIGHT.
JULIE BANDERAS IS BACK.
WHICH IS PRETTY AMAZING GIVEN
YESTERDAY'S BOAT TRIP.
[LAUGHTER]
[SCREAMING]
>> IT WAS A HUGE --
>> Greg: BUT AT LEAST YOU
TRIED IT OUT.
I MEAN, YOU'RE CLOSE.
MICHAEL LOFTUS IS HERE.
AS USUAL HE LOOKS LIKE HE GOT
DRESSED IN THE DARK AT A
HOMELESS SHELTER.
STILL BOXCAR WILLIE'S JACKET.
BUT HE'S HAVING A GREAT SUMMER,
IF ONLY HE AND HIS BUDDIES COULD
LEARN TO THROW FRISBEE.
>> Greg: SOME FRIENDS?
ALL RIGHT, SHUT UP.
SO WE ARE ALL HAPPY TO BE HERE
WITH YOU.
YOU KNOW WHO'S NOT HAPPY?
CNN.
WAS IT DESTINATION FOR NEWS WHEN
TV WAS IN BLACK-AND-WHITE IS NOW
A MOTLEY ASSORTMENT OF GLUM FOR
EGGS TOUTING WITH THE WHAT'S
LEFT OF THEIR SHREDDED
REPUTATION.
THEY ARE CLINGING TO PAST GLORY
AND FULL OF COMMIES.
IT'S A CLOWN CAR MINUS THE CAR.
SO BETWEEN THE FIRST AND
SECOND QUARTER OF THIS YEAR, THE
NETWORK HAS LOST MORE THAN HALF
OF ITS AUDIENCE.
IN NEAR MONTHS, THEY WENT FROM
SIX PEOPLE TRAPPED IN AN AIRPORT
WATCHING DON LEMON CRY TO THREE.
AND THOSE THREE VIEWERS WERE
BAGGAGE HANDLERS ON BREAK.
YEAH, THEY ARE RACING TO THE
BOTTOM FASTER THAN BRIAN STELTER
EATING A CAN OF CONCENTRATED
TOMATO PASTE.
IT'S NOT ELEGANT, BUT IT'S
TASTY.
THERE PRIME TIME HOURS ARE IN
FREE FALL AVERAGING UNDER
1 MILLION VIEWERS.
MEANWHILE IN THE DAYTIME IT'S
ROUGHLY 650,000 VIEWERS BUT I DO
THAT WHEN I DO PILATES ON MY
BALCONY.
RELIABLE SOURCES HOSTED BY
CAPTAIN POP AND FRESH LOST 53%
OF ITS VIEWERS SINCE JANUARY.
REMEMBER, IT'S A TOUGH QUESTION
THAT JEN PSAKI WAS ASKING ON HOW
HE COULD DO HIS JOB BETTER.
STOP WRITING BOOKS ABOUT
FOX NEWS AND REPORT THE NEWS,
YOU SHAVED HAMSTER.
SINCE LAST YEAR, CNN LOST 49% OF
TOTAL VIEWERS.
THEY ARE CHANGING THEIR SLOGAN
FROM THE WORLDWIDE LEADER IN
NEWS TO THE MOST-WATCHED NEWS
RENT NETWORK AT PLANET FITNESS.
MSNBC LOST VIEWERS ALSO SUCCUMB
BUT NOT NEARLY AS MUCH.
YOU CAN'T ATTRIBUTE IT TO SUCH
GENERIC DISINTEREST BUT THEY GOT
HIT LOSING 70% -- IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE GIVEN A COUNTRY
REOPENING AND COMING OUT OF AN
ELECTION.
SOME ARE ARRIVING, SLOW NEWS,
BRIAN KILMEADE.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE GOING
ON WITH CNN.
THEY DON'T HAVE A SINGLE SHOW IN
THE TOP 20.
WHO COULD HAVE PREDICTED THIS?
>> DO YOU MISS ME?
THEY MISS ME.
I KNOW.
THEY LOOK AT THEIR BAD RATINGS
AND THEY ARE SAYING, WE MISS
THIS GUY.
I SAID IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
I WAS WAITING FOR THEM TO
ENDORSE ME, ACTUALLY.
I KNOW THAT WAS A BIG STEP, BUT
THEY ARE GOING DOWN THE TUBES.
THE NUMBERS ARE VERY BAD VERY
BAD.
>> Greg: IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE AND IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
IT'S TRUMP.
ALL CNN HAS GOING FOR IT WAS
BROKEN REMOTE CONTROLS AT
GRANDMA'S AND OF DEEP HATRED FOR
TRUMP AND EVERYTHING ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM.
FROM THERE ONCE 89 MILLION
FOLLOWERS ON TWITTER TO THE GUY
WHO MAKES HIS TACO SALAD.
AND ONCE THE TARGET OF HATRED
LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE, THEIR ONLY
NARRATIVE WAS ORPHANS.
OF COURSE, THEY CONTINUED
LOATHING TRUMP SUPPORTER'S, BUT
IT JUST WASN'T THE SAME.
TO CNN, THE WHITE HOUSE WITHOUT
TRUMP WAS LIKE ONE DIRECTION
WITHOUT ZANE.
GOING TO LET THAT REFERENCE SIT
FOR A WHILE.
SUCH A BIG INTERESTING TARGET
THAT CNN COULD FEED OFF OF HIM
LIKE A GIANT LEECH.
IT WAS AN ENDLESS BUFFET OF
YUMMY STORIES.
REMOVE THAT, YOU SEE CNN FOR
WHAT IT IS.
FIRST, UNAPPEALING AND ANGRY
HOSTS.
CNN WAS KAREN BEFORE KAREN EVEN
EXISTED.
IN FACT, IT'S UNFAIR TO KAREN'S
TO KEEP USING THAT NAME
NEGATIVELY WHEN IT IS REALLY NOT
KAREN, IT IS DON, CHRIS, AND
ANDERSON WERE THERE FOR US.
CNN IS THE ONE STOP SHAMING
NETWORK.
WE NAMED HER WAGGING AND
OVERPAID FINGER.
THEY PASS JUDGMENT LIKE A CATTLE
FARM HOUSES GAS.
CNN WENT FROM RESPECTIVE NEWS TO
A RUMORMONGERING HATE MACHINE.
YOU COULD SAY THEY ARE FOMENTING
RACIAL STRIFE HELPED DESTROY
CITIES.
YOU COULD SAY THEY HAVE MORE
BLOOD ON THEIR HANDS THAN
HANNIBAL LECTOR AFTER LUNCH.
HE COULD SAY THAT BUT I WON'T.
BECAUSE I'M THE TYPE OF VALUE.
BUT ALSO, CNN'S OBSESSION WITH
TRUMP LED TO BOATLOADS OF ERRORS
FROM COLLISION, LAFAYETTE
SQUARE, THE WUHAN LEFT ON THE
UP, DON'T SHOOT, PRUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
THEY WALKED BACK MORE TALES THAN
A TUXEDO DELIVERY SERVICE.
THAT WAS BAD.
BUT THEIR STRATEGY WAS ALWAYS A
PIVOT FROM ONE TRUMP TALE TO
ANOTHER.
NOW THAT HE'S GONE, SO DOES THAT
STRATEGY.
MEANWHILE THE SAME TIME WE SAW
CNN COLLAPSED, SOMETHING ELSE
WAS GOING ON.
"GUTFELD!" WAS THE NUMBER ONE
CABLE NEWS SHOW FOR THE HOUR.
YES!
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S GET THIS, GET THIS FACT,
AT 11:00 WE SURPASSED EVERY CNN
SHOW IN EVERY HOUR, EVERY HOUR
IN TOTAL VIEWERS.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
A FUNKY SHOW AT 11:00 P.M. IS
BEATING ALL OF THEIR SHOWS IN
PRIME TIME.
THAT IS NOT LIKE DAVID BEATING
GOLIATH, IT IS LIKE DAVID
BEATING GOLIATH AND THEN
MARRYING HIS SISTER.
SAVE TO SEE THEM EVERY
THANKSGIVING.
THIS SHOW ALSO TOPPLED SOME
LONG-RUNNING ALLEGED COMEDY
SHOWS ON THE BROADCAST NETWORK
INCLUDING BOTH JIMMY'S.
NOT A BAD START FOR WHAT THE LEG
IS LEGACY MEDIA BRANDED A
CERTAIN FAILURE BUT THEY WANTED
US TO BAIL SO BAD BECAUSE THEY
ARE MISERABLE PEOPLE.
THE FAILED COMEDIANS, THE
UNHAPPY BLOG WRITERS, THE
GAWKERS ON TWITTER.
THEY NEEDED THIS SHOW NOT TO
WORK, BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
WORKING EITHER.
BUT NOW THE NUMBERS ARE IN AND
WE CRUSHED IT.
AND WEIRDLY THEY ARE HAVE GONE.
BUT IT'S NOT OVER YET.
I'M NOT READY TO HAVE THE LAST
LAUGH.
I JUST ENJOY THE FACT THAT WE
ARE ALL LAUGHING.
WE ARE HAVING A GOOD TIME.
WE DON'T TALK DOWN TO THE
VIEWERS.
LET'S BE HONEST, I CAN'T TALK
DOWN TO ANYONE.
BUT WE ARE INTERESTED IN
DIVIDING PEOPLE -- WE DON'T TELL
FAMILY MEMBERS TO INFORM ON
LIBERALS OR TRY TO DIP TO
PLATFORM CNN.
WE WANT YOU TO GO TO BED FEELING
HOPE AND NOT HOPELESS.
WE DON'T THINK THE OTHER SIDE IS
EVIL, WE JUST THINK THEY ARE
WRONG.
BUT THEY THINK WE -- A SHOW
BUILT ON LOVE IS THRIVING.
I MEAN, LOOK AT THE LOVE THAT WE
SHOW EACH OTHER.
>> TYRUS, I'M GLAD YOU GOT
DRESSED TODAY.
YOU ARE NOT A CLEAN PERSON, ARE
YOU?
>> JUDGE, YOU DON'T CARE.
YOU ARE SO RICH.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, I GATHER
YOU JUST GOT OF OF CHARITY FUN
RUN.
>> GROUND, HE REALLY BLEW THAT
SET UP.
WHAT IS SNOBBERY, DEFINED
SNOBBERY.
>> YOU ARE WHITE AND I WOULD SAY
PROBABLY A JERK, RIGHT?
MORGAN, I HOPE YOU LEFT YOUR
MOTORCYCLE AT BACK.
IT'S HARD, BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS TO BEGIN
WITH.
SO DID THEY GO MINUS SIX?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE HE ACTUALLY
MUGGED LIBERACE WITH THAT
JACKET.
ABBY, WELCOME TO THE SHELTER
THIS ISN'T LIKE FOX NATION WHERE
YOU COULD JUST USE THE F WORD
WHENEVER YOU WANT.
>> TO THAT POINT, YOU ARE BAT
[BLEEP] CRAZY.
>> YOU HAVE CHILDREN, WHICH IS A
SCARY THOUGHT.
ONCE AGAIN, I'M GLAD THAT YOU
ARE NOT -- YOU ARE REFUSING TO
GET DRESSED UP FOR THE SHOW.
LAST NIGHT WERE PROBABLY IN SOME
HOTEL ROOM BOMBED OUT OF YOUR
SKULL AND BARELY KNEW WHERE YOU
WERE.
FOX AND FRIENDS IS A LEAD IT
CURVY COUCHES AND YOUR COOKING
SEGMENTS YOU THINK YOU CAN COME
UP IN HERE --
>> YOU ARE SHUTTING COME YOU
DON'T GO OUT VERY OFTEN.
KAT, BEFORE YOU GOT MARRIED, YOU
WERE FILTHY.
YOU DIDN'T GO STRAIGHT TO BED.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THAT IS LOVE.
AND MAY BE OUR SUCCESS AND
SENSITIVITY CAN TEACH CNN
SOMETHING.
MAYBE THEY WILL LOOK AT GOT
FOULED AND GO, YOU KNOW IT
CUMMINGS MORE THAN JUST A PRETTY
FACE.
HE'S ALSO VERY SHORT.
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE IS SAUCIER THAN AN EXPLOSIVE
RACCOON FACTORY, FOX NEWS
ANCHOR.
HE IS THE FORMER AG WHO CAN
BENCH PRESS YOU AND ME, FORMER
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
MATT WHITAKER.
WHEN HOMELESS PEOPLE SEE HIM,
THEY GIVE HIM SPARE CHANGE,
EDITOR IN CHIEF MICHAEL LOFTUS.
AND THEY CALL HER A BOTTLE
BLONDE, BECAUSE SHE BROUGHT IT
TO HER HAIR APPOINTMENT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT.
JULIE, QUITE IMPRESSIVE START
FOR THAT SHOW.
FEEL FREE TO --
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Greg: FEEL FREE TO
COMPLEMENT ME AND BY SUCCESS.
SHOWER ME WITH PRAISE.
OR JUST SHOWER ME.
>> I THINK EVERY TIME YOU
COULD'VE COME ON -- EVERY TIME
I'VE COME ON YOUR RATINGS HAVE
BEEN GREAT.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF YOU.
YOU'VE COME A FAR WAY BACK WHEN
YOU STARTED RIGHT I TO
GLORIOUSLY GOING TO A THREE HOUR
INTRO THERE WITHOUT STUMBLING
ONCE, WHICH IS QUITE FRANKLY,
AMERICO.
>> Greg: I KNOW IT'S A
SURPRISE I CAN EVEN TALK.
>> I'M HONESTLY REALLY
IMPRESSED, YOU'VE COME FAR.
>> Greg: YES, YES.
WHAT DO YOU SEE, MATT, AS THE
FUTURE FOR CABLE NEWS?
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THEY
ARE IN A DOWNWARD SPIRAL, EXCEPT
FOR FOX, OF COURSE.
WE ARE ON AN UPWARD SPIRAL.
WE HAVE NOW REACHED A POINT IN
OUR SOCIETY WHERE THIS IS
ENTERTAINMENT PUT THE NEWS AS
ENTERTAINMENT PAIR THAT IS WHAT
TRUMP BRIDGED AND NOW SLEEPY
JOE BIDEN IS NOT ENTERTAINING
US.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TURNING
IT OFF.
AND THAT IS WHY YOU ARE SEEING
YOUR SHOW AS GREAT AS IT IS,
WHEN WE ARE IN THE SHOW IT'S
BETTER.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT IT'S ENTERTAINMENT.
POLITICS IS NOW ENTERTAINMENT
PEER THIS IS WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE LOOK FOR.
>> THE THING ABOUT FOX THAT IS
DIFFERENT THAN CNN IS THAT WE
ARE ACTUALLY PEOPLE.
>> WEIGHT --
>> Greg: IF CNN -- CNN, THEY
ALL JUST VARIATIONS OF ONE
PERSON.
BUT FOX IS ALL DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
AND SO THAT PEOPLE DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE ON
THIS NETWORK AND FEEL LIKE THEY
KNOW THEM.
AND THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN WHEN
YOU TURN ON CNN AND EVERYBODY
SEES A DIFFERENT VERSION OF
ANDERSON COOPER.
AND YOU ARE PUTTING YOUR FINGER
TO YOUR MOUTH LIKE YOU HAVE A
THOUGHT.
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE IT'S FOX &
FRIENDS.
>> DON'T JUMP AHEAD TO.
YOU THINK I'M KIDDING.
THAT IS WHAT YOU CALL A LONG
TEASE.
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO THAT
STORY.
THE OTHER THING TOO IS THAT I
THINK ONCE TRUMP STARTED
HAMMERING THE PHRASE "FAKE
NEWS," WHICH WASN'T A NEW IDEA.
BUT ONCE IT WAS COMING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THAT HE WAS
DOING IT EVERY DAY, IT CHANGED
THE MEDIA WHO THEN HAD TO DEFEND
ITSELF, BUT COULDN'T.
SPEAK OF THE WHOLE THING IS
WONDERFUL.
THE SUCCESS OF THE SHOW IS TRULY
IT'S A REMINDER THAT WE ARE NOT
CRAZY, BECAUSE FOR YEARS, YEARS,
AND YEARS, ALL OF THESE LEAD TO
THE LEFT.
AND THEN YOU ARE LIKE OKAY, SO
I'M NOT CRAZY.
AND WHEN TRUMP WAS ELECTED, THE
MASK CAME OFF AND CNN WERE JUST
LIKE TRUMP JUNKIES.
THOSE POOR PEOPLE WHO WOULD
WATCH CNN AND REALLY BELIEVE
IT -- TODAY IS THE DAY THEY ARE
GOING TO GET THEM.
THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IMPUTE
THOSE POOR PEOPLE -- THE
ADRENALINE RUSH.
THEY ARE NOT WATCHING CNN,
BECAUSE THEY ARE COLLAPSED IN
THE BATHROOM SOBBING AND JUST
ROCKING THEMSELVES -- IT'S
HORRIBLE.
>> YOU KNOW THAT FEELING
INTIMATELY.
>> I DO.
>> Greg: I'M JUST HAPPY YOU
CLAIM ALMOST CLEANED YOURSELF
UP.
EVERYBODY USES THE PHRASE
"KAREN" AND IT IS UNFAIR TO
WOMEN NAMED CAMERON BECAUSE IT'S
ALMOST BIGOTED, BUT CNN IS MORE
LIKE GLADYS FROM BEWITCHED.
REMEMBER GLADYS WAS THE
NEXT-DOOR NEIGHBOR AND
CONSTANTLY CONSUMED, HATED TO BE
WITH FAMILY.
BUT WAS CONSUMED BY THEM BY
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED BEFORE CATS BIRTH.
>> IS GOOD TO SAY YOU HAVE TO
GIVE DIFFERENT CULTURAL
REFERENCE.
>> IT'S LIKE A NOSY NEIGHBOR
THAT'S OBSESSED WITH YOU.
THEY HATE YOU, HATE YOU, HATE
YOU.
BUT THE RELIABLE SOURCES -- IT'S
ABOUT FOX NEWS.
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT FOX NEWS,
NOTHING ELSE.
SO WHEN DO YOU SEE THIS GOING?
I'D LIKE TO SAY YOU DESERVE
PARTIAL CREDIT FOR THIS SUCCESS
OF THE SHOW.
BUT I'LL LEAVE THAT UP TO THE
VIEWERS.
>> NO, IF YOU HAD TO COME AND I
UNDERSTAND -- ALSO, EVERYONE --
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO BRING ME ALONG
ON THIS JOURNEY AS THEY CALL IT
ON THE BACHELOR AND THE
BACHELORETTE.
I THINK IT'S AWESOME COME I
THINK IT'S GREAT THAT WE TALK
ABOUT STUFF THAT OTHER PEOPLE
DON'T TALK ABOUT.
NOT EVERYBODY HAS THE EXACT SAME
POINT OF VIEW ON THE SHOW.
AND LIKE YOU SAID, WE ARE
STARTING WITH THIS OR ENDING THE
SHOW WITH BEASTIE HOLIDAY, YOU
DON'T SEE THAT ON CNN.
>> NO, YOU DON'T.
>> PRODUCE AND WE ARE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT [BLEEP].
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, THE STORY
IS AN INTERESTING DEBATE THAT IS
RAGING IN SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT IT HAPPENS TO INVOLVE A
WOMAN MAKING OUT WITH A DOG.
>> THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M A FORMER PROSECUTOR.
ACTUALLY, I THINK IN EVERY STATE
IT IS BANNED.
LET'S JUST SEE THE SHOW AND
REVERSE.
>> DEFINED MAKING OUT.
>> Greg: I CAN'T BELIEVE WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS I